I am thrilled this evening.
We have an excellent show for you tonight.
And as always, whoever has the most whammy points
will go straight onto a double bonus,
but before we get to that.
(audience laughing)
I'm sorry, who the hell was that?
Now, wait a minute, wait a minute.
Which camera is mine?
Am I camera three, or am I camera two?
Or is it one?
Stan, goddammit, can somebody tell me what camera I am?!
[Conan] Okay.
Sir, please, excuse me, sir!
Sir!
Three, two, one,
and here we go!
Hello, folks, and welcome back
to America's favorite game show, Fill in the Blanks!
I am your host--
(audience cheering)
That's right!
No.
It truly is America's favorite!
I am your host Reed Newport, just like the cigarettes!
Yep!
(audience laughing)
Menthols are the ones I prefer most,
and the survey says!
(bell dinging)
All right, look, hey!
I am sorry, sir.
I think you're in the wrong studio.
500 more points, and that will take us straight
to an All or Nothing.
Conan, I don't think that guy can hear you.
I've heard about him.
He's this leftover game show host from the '80s.
He's wandered the studio lot for decades
since his show was canceled.
Let's say hello to Natasha from Clearwater, Florida!
(audience cheering)
Natasha, I understand that you're an algebra teacher.
How long have you been an algebra teacher?
12 years.
12 years!
Well, that's just about how long it takes.
(audience laughing)
Excuse me, would you please leave my audience alone?
Hey, let's get to know Dickie St. Wayne,
all the way from Amarillo, Texas.
Dickie, I understand you run a honey farm.
What's that like?
Sticky.
(audience laughing)
Dickie, you just said our secret word!
(alarm blaring)
(audience applauding)
No, no, no!
Connie, tell 'em what they've won!
Look at that!
It's our grand prize!
(audience cheering)
Looking good, Connie!
It's a personal water sport device from Takahomi.
Now, this is strictly illegal in the United States,
but folks, if you're on international waters,
let it rip!
I'm sorry.
You know, we cannot afford that!
We can't afford that!
And the survey says!
(buzzer sounds)
Oh!
Tough break!
I honestly don't know what's going, I...
30 seconds on the clock, and it's just about time
to find out what's inside the box!
We've eliminated both Carl and Brenda,
which leaves only Carrie,
and I hope she doesn't spend all of her gimme points
before it's time to pull that lever!
(audience cheering)
No!
There's no!
(audience cheering)
No!
Pull that lever!
It's not a game show!
It's lever time!
[Conan] No!
Here comes the lever!
Stop!
Stop it!
There's no game show!
Reed!
Reed Newport, can you hear me?!
Did someone say my name?
Do I hear my name somewhere?
I can see the outline of a very tall girl scout.
Oh, for God's sake!
(audience laughing)
Just stop! Stop!
Well, the only way to stop it, Conan,
is to press that red button right in front of you.
Listen, there's no red button.
Pull that lever!
No!
(audience cheering)
There's no lever!
There's no red button!
Conan.
Looks like it's time to ring that bell!
There's no bell!
(bell ringing)
Ready to take another spin at the wheel?!
There's no wheel!
Reed, this is painful and hard for you to accept.
Your show went away
a long, long time ago.
(audience sighing)
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, but it did, and this is sad.
It's time to stop.
Well, maybe you're right.
Maybe it is time to take a break.
Maybe I should pack up my things and cash in my pension.
No, no, no, I--
(audience sighing)
It's okay.
No.
It's what he needs to do.
This is good for me because I think I really should move
all the way to the bonus round!
No!
(audience cheering)
That's right, folks!
The bonus round is just like the lightning round,
except it's nowhere near as fast.
Here I go into the isolation booth.
Ladies and gentlemen--
Now, when I'm in here,
circle takes the X, and I won't hear
anything you say.
I'm sorry.
That's Reed Newport.
We'll get him a doctor.
He'll be fine.
Terrific show tonight.
From the new movie Overboard,
Eva Longoria is on the program!
(audience cheering)
Very exciting!
[Reed] Conan, Conan, I think she prefers
to be called Ava Longoria.
No, no, no, it's Eva!
It's not Ava!
Shut up!
Well.
From the HBO series Westworld,
Luke Hemsworth is on the program!
(audience cheering)
[Reed] Luke Hemsworth, all the way from Amarillo, Texas!
He runs a honey farm.
All right.
(audience laughing)
Shut up.
Thrilled, musical guests
Ben Harper, Charlie Musselwhite on the show!
(audience cheering)
[Reed] Conan, is that your final answer?
Would you like to phone the audience?
We're gonna take a break.
We're gonna take a break!
We'll be right back.
Jimmy, take it away.
(audience cheering)
Promotional consideration for,
I beg your pardon?
What's the matter?
Everything's going just fine!
Look, pull that lever!
Pull that lever!
Come on in the isolation booth.
[Conan] Oh, it's nice!